incoming bonus content
my halloween makeup series the mask
friendly spiderweb eyes disclaimer this
one isn't super easy but if you take
your time and have some patience do it
step by step you can totally do it i
believe in you okay so i did my
foundation concealer powder and eyebrows
added my trusty washi tape from the
craft store now using liquid liner and
black eyeshadow i'm gonna build out a
big cat eye and those are gonna be the
ends of the spider webs now you'll take
your black liquid liner and draw three
lines coming down from your eye just
like this then for the curved web lines
you'll go right up like this one two
three and you'll continue that right
down have a cotton swab ready in case
you make mistakes honestly even if it's
not perfect it's still gonna look really
cool you can even draw a straight line
down and draw a cute little spider look
how cute she is add some black liner and
some shadow to your eye and you can
either be done there or take it up a
notch and add some more definition by
using a white eyeliner and smudging out
the lines with a gray or black eyeshadow
this is the perfect easy look for a safe
and happy mask wearing halloween that
was quite a treat